for coming to this afternoon session i'm
very pleased to introduce belinda zen
who is going to be speaking on a mean
field theory of lazy training in
two-layer two-layer neural nets thank
you very much
hi everyone so this is joint work with
my advisor max roginsky and we are from
the cornfields of central illinois
so um just to note
all the work i'm gonna describe here is
going to be in continuous time it can be
reported to a discrete time pretty
straightforwardly but that's sort of not
where the novelty lies so
we'll leave that aside for now
what's of interest here is for a
specific class of problems given in the
title
we're interested in
comparing the
laundromat diffusion's convergence to
the gibbs
which we know
happens in general to
what's in some sense the most efficient
way of attaining the kids in finite time
and we'll make that clear later but
most efficient will be in a strict
control theoretic sense
so to get started um let me just set up
the problem we're interested in
having a set of data inputs x labels y
labels and the reals
and some sort of predictor
that is
a sum of
a non-linear function of the data and
weights
over some very large set of weights
i'm interested in evaluating this
predictor relative to the squared loss
and considering what happens as the
number of neurons goes to infinity so
the mean view limit where they're all
exchangeable
and probably most of you are familiar
with this problem by now it's
like several years old but i should
probably motivate it
because for
most of you who haven't been living
under a rock you've probably heard that
you probably know very well that
real networks benefit from very great
depth rather than what for example
facebook and google are using very deep
rather than very wide networks to
classify
all the things
and in fact we have some essential
benefits of depth results that are
all lower bounds with respect to the
width you need to trade off for depth
so they're all of roughly the form
there's just some function that's
efficiently approximable by
neural networks of some depth that is
not small but if you want to approximate
the same function with a shallow network
so the same accuracy you have to incur
a cost in width that's exponential in
dimension
so there are a lot of results
in this vein
and
essentially
they all deal with
uniformly ish oscillatory functions
where
depth helps you a lot but
which will
be penalized greatly when you try to
reduce depth and
approximately the same thing with
something very wide
now we care because to back up like to
the 80s and 90s we we're just in neural
networks
because of the so-called universal
approximation property which says that
even shell networks with a single hidden
layer
can approximate
basically any interesting function to
arbitrary accuracy
and here
almost every interesting function
would be continuous functions over a
compact set so it's really not
restrictive
the only catch being that well you might
actually have to pay for dimensionality
here
but that's fine i guess if you want to
take your neurons to infinity and
in fact
all the results along these lines
did not care about because of
dimensionality
and on the other hand there's also been
as i'm sure most of you have heard
and are aware of and are involved in uh
work on
so-called lazy training which says that
in many cases
when we have very wide shallow networks
training with sgd
does not result in the way it's moving
very much which is the so-called lazy
training regime
now of course
there are some caveats here concerning
the width of the network relative to a
number of data points so called over
parameterization
which is very sensible and kind of
necessary if you think about it
there's also relationships to the step
size
so if you go too aggressively you will
exit this regime
your connections to margin and stopping
and
so forth and of course there's also the
connection to the so-called ntk the
neural tangent kernel which says that
well if the weights don't move very much
then they're
close to
the linearization around initialization
which says that well
then that's kind of disturbing because
here we have this highly non-linear
function
and we're saying that it's closely
approximated by something linear
and luckily we have caveats that say
well this happens only sometimes
so now that i've motivated this mean
field limit it's
kind of immediate how we would transfer
this whole thing to this case of
measures instead of having
an empirical distribution of the weights
we have
instead
a measure over the weights
and likewise instead of considering the
risk
given by
a very large collection of weights we
have the risk relative to
a measure over the weights
and here notationally this won't be
super important but just to
make it clear this our zero term is
the model independent data term
the f tilde term is the cross terms with
respect to the model and data
and this
k term under the integral is comprises
the uh quadratic terms
so it looks a little weird but we'll
replace this notation in a little bit
and now that we've set up this um
measure theoretic formulation
we can also think of the laziness of
training as entropic regularization
where instead of considering minimizing
just the risk of the weight of the
measure we consider minimizing
the free energy functional compressing
the risk
at some terminal time
and some divergence
relative to some sort of prior on the
weights
the prior reflecting initialization
and note that this is sort of not a new
idea for example made out of this back
in 2018 where they're regularizing with
respect to the leg measure so relative
to some sort of
uniform prior over weights and here
we're considering
as i'm sure you all know initialization
is often gaussian
or regularizing with respect to a
gaussian and because we're expecting
that
laziness of training is absurd whenever
we
stop the algorithm at least up to some
time finite time t and upper bound then
we can say moreover that this holds
pathwise and we can regularize instead
the path measure over the weights
relative to instead of a gaussian the
winner process from zero to t so
regularizing the evolution
of this path measure relative to a brand
new motion truncated at t
and here we have two parameters of
interest we have this
familiar probably to mostly inverse
temperature parameter which will come
into play when we discuss the gibbs
distribution and of course we have this
uh optimization time
t which will also affect the strength of
the regularization so as
you optimize for longer this prior
becomes more diffused variance grows
and so we're regularizing less as we go
over time
okay so as i just
foreshadowed free energy minimization is
going to be a matter of balancing two
different considerations so
of course i'm going to care as before
about the risk at the terminal time t
necessarily but also we're going to care
about the pathwise behavior
of this measure relative to the winner
process over the same time interval
so trading off risk minimization and
entropic regularization
and so you might ask okay didn't i just
make things really complicated by making
this pathway rather than just
considering the um
terminal risk and the terminal diverges
and
maybe yes but optimality says no because
in fact we can
decompose the divergence term using the
chain rule for kl which will give us
well if we choose correctly
the divergence at the terminal time and
then the divergence
over the interval from zero up to t open
and point at t conditioned on what
happens the realization at time t
so if you look at this thing then
especially the first term you'll notice
that
the integrand okay it's this nasty
conditional pathwise thing but it's
actually independent of the terminal
density that you achieve
so by optimality remember kl is not
negative
then whatever the terminal density is mu
t
mu t almost surely that thing has to be
a brownian bridge so that it corresponds
to the wiener measure pinned at whatever
it's pinned at at time t
so then indeed in fact the entire
integral goes away and we're left with
a static problem we're optimizing
without also generality over the cosmic
random bridges that don't have that
nasty pathway term
so free energy minimization over
path measure becomes
one of the risk of the terminal time and
the divergence at the terminal time so
we didn't actually
uh end up with a much higher problem
moreover because this free energy is
strongly condensed in the
terminal density there exists a unique
optimal measure and it's characterized
by this so-called boltzmann fixed point
condition that looks like this
so it
comprises a potential within the
temperature beta and
the gaussian that reflects the strength
of regularization or optimization time
and
if you're looking at this boltzmann
fixed point condition being like okay
where did this come from um i would just
ask you to consider for a quick and
dirty way of getting at this no
regularity conditions whatever
to just
because this free energy
functional is strictly convex just take
the functional derivative set it to zero
and solve for
mu t and there you go of course it's a
lot it's a lot more
delicate than that but just so that this
thing was almost very mysterious
okay so
some of you may have looked at this
pathways divergence minimization but
like okay it looks kind of familiar like
some plastic problem
and for those who know this classic
problem
well it's the schrodinger bridge problem
which asks for some diffusion process
that puts some drift on top of
standard brand emotion
over one over sometimes zero to t
finite t
what is the way of achieving some
desired terminal distribution such that
we minimize the total work done
from zero to t so total work done here
being euclidean norm squared
of your control or drift over this
interval
and this is a
an occam's razor consideration which is
morally sort of what we want if we don't
get to observe this process at various
times in between
it's a prior towards
a very sort of gradual evolution of this
process rather than saying okay well
we're not looking at it but we assume
that there can be some like strong force
that randomly comes in and strongly
perturbs it at random intervals
and your sonos theorem will tell us that
well lo and behold
this expected total work done is nothing
other than
the pathwise kl between the uncontrolled
and the control process
hopefully things are looking like
they're coming together a little bit
and where are we going with this
well from there it's kind of immediate
that we would
be able to set up an optimal control
problem which says that okay for a
diffusion process which is your standard
branding motion with some drift attached
to it
what is the drift or control
such that
the law of the process minimizes this
free energy function the one we
described before
and note that this has a very different
flavor from asking about the mixing time
of the longitude diffusion process so
it's not saying how fast can this thing
get to the gibbs distribution it's
actually saying
well we want to get to begins exactly by
some finite time
and of course that's a lot more
ambitious and that i mean if you think
about it that should cost us in various
ways
okay so to fully make this a control
problem again we say that okay we have a
diffusion process which is a drifter
control on top of a wiener process we're
not touching the winner process itself
we want to minimize the expected cost
comprising this
running cost control cost and
a terminal cost where here the terminal
cost is the risk attained by
the terminal measure
so i mean it looks like your standard
control problem set up you'll get a
value function out of this somewhere
right but
okay like life is actually bad here
because
now this
like by optimality this process is going
to incur
the dependence on this
terminal condition terminal cost this
risk at the terminal time
and this dependence is going to
propagate in ways that we're generally
not going to know how to deal with it's
an instance of making loss of dynamics
which
are generally not analytically tractable
because they have an evolution
of the optimal density governed by
this
couple set of four backward equations so
we have the naturally the [ __ ] or pump
equation forward
here we're starting from zero
direct delta zero
and we have the hdb equation governing
the evolution of the value function
going backwards
and with a
terminal condition
that is
given by what
we would say is the
the cost the risk contribution of
the
the weight given by the space variable
and if the hgb equation doesn't look as
friendly to you as the focker pump which
i assume you're all very friendly with
then i will ask that you consider the
bellman equation in discrete time
the necessary dynamic programming
iterate for optimality and then take the
limit of the time step to zero and
convince yourself that it should look
something like this gradients will
have to appear because of optimality
okay so we have this hdb equation and
okay what do we do with it well
corresponds to the calcium problem and
has this sort of terminal condition
and what do we do with it well luckily
in our case we can
perform a log transform on it
and get back
another calcium problem one that is a
lot nicer looking
and here the terminal condition we've
gotten rid of any dependencies on things
that
are independent of the space variable
and lo and behold uh feminine cuts gives
us the solution to this
new calcium problem and then we invert
the transform and we get back
what should be our value function and if
you look at this and you're somewhat
familiar with control you'll say that
well yes it looks something like what it
should look like it's
an expectation over
what you what you want at the terminal
time given where you are space variable
the given time t
okay so what does the optimal control
look like well like we said the optimal
control should be something like
a negative grad of the value function
because well when the control cost is
your
euclidean norm of the control
squared then
well you don't want to be wasting any
controller going in directions that are
not minimizing your value function
but by optimality this sort of has to be
the case
and that's not a useful characterization
of course unless we actually know the
value function
and here it's a matter of okay now we
have this kind of value function and
let's ensure that it satisfies all our
necessary conditions
so if we plug in negative great of the
value function as our control
then we actually
get that the marginal satisfies via the
poker punch equation nothing other than
our boltzmann fixed point condition
which tells us that the terminal density
is in fact that satisfying the pulse of
this one condition and therefore the
whole thing solves the hgb equation
and we are done
and earlier i promised you that
optimality would have to be
characterized by a brand new bridge
so if we plug this in carefully then
what we get in fact is that
the optimal control looks something like
this
log
of
this quantity
and it's known as the former drift
so here we see that informer drift has
been characterized as getting more
desperate
when you're far away as time
approaches your
terminal time so sort of a
deadline consideration like the further
away the more desperate
you are as you get closer to your
deadline
now if you stare at this a little bit
more and you're familiar with the
sd corresponding to a brand new bridge
you will say that hey this looks
somewhat familiar
and in fact our function f here
corresponding to
a potential above is actually just the
density of our optimal measure
relative to the terminal gaussian
and so in fact it is just
the
grounding bridge where the terminal
condition is marginalized over all
possible realizations
relative to
new star t
okay so i told you that you can get this
value function and at the end of the day
you have this former drift that is an
optimal control and so life is good but
it's not actually good because well you
should have some exceptions which are
that first
well optimal control requires knowing
your desired terminal distribution
you're characterized by the boltzmann
six-point condition
which is all great if what we want is to
be able to sample efficiently from this
terminal distribution but here we're
actually trying to arrive at it so
there's some matter of like putting the
cart before the horse
and secondly
there's the fact that while lazy
training happens so isn't this optimal
control approach somewhat overkill in
the sense that
well
some greater approach such as hdd or in
continuous time or longitude diffusion
should be able to do nearly as well
right why do you need optimal control if
some
greedy algorithm that it will just give
you some thing that's nicely and
tropically regularized anyway
and to that end we might want to compare
following three processes we have
the
process given by the optimal controller
forward drift this brownian bridge
type thing
which has a nasty expectation that you
know you probably don't want to
implement you probably don't know how to
implement
versus
the overdamped launch one using
the optimal law which is
seemingly more tractable but we saw this
optimal law to deal with and then versus
longitude with
not the optimal law but the law at any
given time t
which should be the most
which would be implementable and like
the most same counterpart you would want
so here we have as before our two
degrees of freedom we have beta the
inverse temperature parameter and t are
optimization time
remember temperature plays
the role it plays
in most of these considerations
so it's going to affect the distribution
in the sense of the sharpness around the
modes
whereas
t is going to the time is going to go
from the strength of this regularization
with respect to the gaussian the longer
you optimize
the weaker this regularization
and
so there will be various tradeoffs
between
beta and t and the question is well how
exactly do they interact and
in what cases and what regimes might
launch in with
various traces of beta and t be
comparable to
the optimal form of drift or will never
be
okay so what cases are we interested in
well first of all there is the
ultimate fixed point condition again and
we can reason about
the potential in various ways if it's
strongly convex we expect that life will
be good right if it's
non-convex well life will be not so good
but we can also consider when it's
almost convex or semiconducts so
convex if you add some
smallish
quadratic term to it
or when it's hopelessly non-complex
where
no matter what you do
it's very very far off from being
complex
so we're going to
get at these considerations via
what are known as log buildable of
inequalities which tell us about the
convergence in washer sign two distance
to the gibbs distribution of a
longitudinal diffusion so
if
something satisfies a
log syllable of inequality with constant
c
then it will converge exponentially fast
in
the reciprocal of c
over time so small also of inequality is
constant sorry is
good and large is going to make life
very difficult
so in our strongly convex case you know
we can't really
make any statements about the potential
in general but the quadratic regularizer
will dominate
and so all in all this thing this
regularized potential will be extremely
convex
and life will be good here
we have
a strong conductor parameter of
one over t minus the capital where
capital is
of course
what could be the maximum concavity of
this
this potential so to speak
then we have a
in the complex case that logs are blood
constant as follows so if we choose
beta times t to be
the
factor of one over capital then
our logs of love constant will be
something that's
of t
and
life will be generally pretty good
we'll converge exponentially faster
against distribution
and
sorry
[Music]
distribution and
why accuracy epsilon will incur
this cost of additional cost of log one
over epsilon
which can be sort of viewed as
the price you pay for
algorithmically for step size
in terms of the smoothness as you
approach optimality so recall that
vulner knows where it wants to go and
knows when i want to get there by so you
can adjust the step size accordingly but
here
you're paying this one over
epsilon term because well you don't know
you're just being greedy and
as you get closer to convergence
then
you're dealing with water and water
regions and you're not being as
efficient
and here's devices that choose
time t
being one over one sorry of epsilon and
we're good to go we get convergence
pretty fast
and sort of on the other hand if this
potential even with the quadratic
regularizer is
not convex then life will be hard
the logs of bulb inequality will incur a
cost that's
one
will be of size exponential in dimension
and
what does that mean
well that just means that
here the choices of beta and t do not
correspond to lazy's training in the
sense that
former will get you
to the optimum exactly by time t but
just to get epsilon close
so we're not even talking exactly just
that's long close
spongebob will require an additional
factor of exponential and dimension
amount of time to get there
and that's kind of what we'd expect if
this quadratic
regularization corresponding to this
entropic regular regularization with
respect to the gaussian is
pretty weak
okay so now we're left with cancer okay
there's this
qualitative gap between the convex case
and the non-conduct case
so
in convex case we have
loads so we'll have inequality it looks
a good thing on the right sorry on the
left and in the non-convex case we get
this
exponential dimension
cost
so
sort of
philosophically that's what you want in
the sense that
well things that are convex are
qualitatively very different from things
that are
non-convex on the other hand we're not
making this a problem about convex or
concave and long concave densities
because it's not very interesting but
also because
well if we're going with the metaphor of
lazy training laziness is sort of this
behavior and as such it's
sort of
more on a continuum rather than
something that's dichotomous
so we don't want to say it is something
lazy or is it not you know just like how
easy
and then can we get at that
so if we look more closely at the
logs of life constant for the non-convex
case we'll see why it has this
exponential dependence
on dimension which is that
this xd term
comes from
the
maximum fluctuation of
this
what we call g here is potential
those are some
compact set that could be of size
sort of uh
routine
so if you think about it well this is
actually pretty
bad in the sense that a strongly
conducts
function
will have a pretty bad log support
constant using this bound but obviously
it will have a very good one using the
correct one which accounts for convexity
so what can we do about this
well we can decompose this
semiconductor potential into a convex
portion and
sort of this
non-convex slot portion which we'll
assume is
bounded in
in magnitude and from here we can say
okay well we can use a perturbation
argument to say that
yes we'll have this xd term but it's
actually not going to be very large
there'll be some small constant in front
of it that'll make things tractable
or we'll see where we can say that well
because we're interested in the dynamics
specifically we'll just use gersonov and
say that we can
reason about the convergence of the
convex portion
which is exponentially fast and then
the divergence incurred by this
non-convex slop portion which will be
bounded and not so huge over some not
very long time t
and it'll be on the order of
this non-convex
magnitude m squared t and if m is not
large by assumption then again we can
choose t to be
of epsilon hiding some
number of which is confidence and we're
good to go
okay so the last part would be
comparing monument with the optimal law
versus the time t law which is what we
could actually hope to implement
so when we look at these two processes
well we're going to say that the strong
solutions
any two strong solutions will
evolve with the
difference in norm it looks like this
so nothing fancy here this is
an equality and
the thing to note here is that we have
this minus 1 over t term
and then this beta term
which
will account for
some difference between
the law at time t and the optimal law at
any given time
and here the difficulty is that well
no matter how you slice it
that difference between ut and you start
is going to
be difficult to deal with
and it's going to affect
basically any
any two strong solutions so even an
optimal coupling will have to
wrangle with this difference somehow
and also morally we can reason about
we could probably say that we should we
can reason about the licious constants
of
of the optimal potential potential with
mu star because it should be nice in
various ways but
just say that we have nice lipschitz
constants for muti for any
ut and initialization is sort of
an iffy proposition we don't really want
to do that
and in fact what can be said in the
general mkb case is that
if this mkv term here
beta or negative beta is
not
small enough then in fact there will be
multiple stationary distributions and
life will be very hard and it will be
just very difficult to talk about
conversions
so morally what we need here is to say
that well
one over t is a lot greater than beta
so that
this process is sufficiently ornstein
ulumbak like
and the
mkb term is not going to
pose too many problems
and we're left with something that's
bounded and highly regularized
okay that's all i have i guess there's
like five minutes left for questions so
if anyone has any questions go for it i
guess
thank you very much let's thank uh
belinda for that wonderful talk
and are there any questions
here
sure so this is just a very general
question um
what would be an example of a
distribution that you would want to
sample from or this would be
uh
the the the best method that you could
choose you know like what is somehow
obviously uh there are other methods
that were great for log concave
distributions but this this has
you know significant tolerance to
non-convexity
what's the what's this the sampling
problem that you have in your mind when
you're thinking about this type of of
method
[Music]
um sampling or optimization
because here the former drift is very
useful for
sampling in fact it's
by definition it's
the most efficient way to sample from
some desired
distribution at some finite time t
if you know that distribution
and it's most efficient in this
work done l2 norm squared sense
but here in this optimization problem
we're saying that okay we're going to
achieve some
optimal distribution at time do you hear
the boltzmann fixed point condition
satisfying that minimizes our free
energy functional but
it's
not actually going to
be useful in the sense that we'll we
can't
get there ahead of time because we don't
know mu star satisfying point condition
so here the problem is we're comparing
the lodgement algorithm
with appropriate law to fulmer and
saying though why lazy training happens
which means that
we can
achieve optimality pretty efficiently so
how close is or how efficient is
efficient
that answer your question at all
okay great um any other questions
and okay i may have answered lan's
question as well
you know
all right okay then let's thank belinda
again thank you
[Applause]
thank you all for
participating
okay and so we'll begin again and maybe
it tin till